I've played a lot of VR in my time since
the very beginning of the oculus I have
played VR and I've loved it as an
experience as a new way of experiencing
games in virtual reality in general it
went from a dream to reality
well not reality virtual reality and so
what that offers is a stepping stone to
get to the point where we are right now
and where we are right now is with the
oculus quest
oh god you can see how I'm recording
this this video is sponsored by oculus
forgive the way that I'm filming this
I'm filming this on my phone and that
makes no sense for an unboxing video
normally it's aesthetically pleasing but
I'm not good at that sort of stuff so
I'm just gonna go ramshackle and
everyone's gonna be hating me for the
way that I do this although I don't even
have a stand for my phone I gotta figure
out a way to prop that one thing if my
calculations are correct this is
pointing in the right place I think I
gotta do the video like this is that
pointing in the right place god I hope
so I only have one of these to open if
this is not pointing in the right place
I am so screwed okay know how to fix
this okay so I've got my tablet here
what am I do is I'm going to put this
behind my phone and then point it at my
phone ha ha ha Oh God low battery who
cares just last god I need something
else to take a picture of the way that
I'm filming this because it's so
ridiculous that I just need to document
it and this is the most absurd thing
I've ever done but it's working there's
my phone that's my air conditioner
remote that's my iPad up against a chair
so that I can see that screen through
this screen so I know this is pointed at
this this makes sense
no well shut up I I'm just trying to
make I'm just right so this is the
oculus quest it is a completely
stand-alone VR system ever since the
very beginning of VR when I played dumb
P goes elephant I don't remember what
the actual name was but ever since I
played dumb P the game I loved VR but I
always thought that
day that VR became wireless would be a
beautiful day indeed and that day is
today you can get this right now this is
available and it's not the crazy prices
of what VR is this is 399 its standalone
at a good price
the future is now when it comes to VR
and I'm not just saying this because I
don't know obviously it's boxed up but I
have played this I already know this is
legit oh god I don't how do I open you
my own shot I'm not sure I do have to
talk like this
I'll just get I don't know also tag it
video of this ludicrousness so well
that's not even if pointed in the right
direction
oh don't ruin everything oh no no there
we go got it okay dude stop stop god
damn it I am just a human travesty there
okay my iPad is gonna die any second now
I gotta get this underway um so now I'm
recording from two different angles
because I don't know why o ye gods who
made plastic this strong on burnin
valuable battery life here oh please
just open open damn you open you you've
got no seams this is impossible how
could anybody here we go I think it
burgers oh there we go I found a weak
point okay
huh Christmas morning is gonna be real
stressful I don't think it's that tough
to open I just think I'm an idiot okay
that goes off and then you've got the
dramatic reveal of the oculus quest in
all its glory that's it this is it
that's the thing it's the headset it's
the controllers it's a charging cable
because the batteries in here that's the
thing know what I mean that's pretty
cool it's pretty cool to me just because
I love the idea that you know you can
just have VR now all in this in a
lightweight headset you just have
everything you need to do VR the
tracking is done from the inside meaning
there are sensors in the corners of this
the tracker room for you it's that
got your controllers with your straps
your safety straps you don't want any
broken TVs so use your straps you've got
a spacer if you're the type that wears
classes which I am sometimes batteries
for the controllers are included good
feature and your your cable to charge up
the thing this is it
headset controllers batteries plug but
cable that's it and then you're in VR
alright so I'm gonna cut to being in VR
okay alright quick couple that's all she
wrote I'm in VR it's really that simple
all I needed to do was go on my phone
get an app set it up and I'm in that's
literally all there is and then you can
get into a game and as you can see I
have no wires which is amazing
I cannot overstate how much I love the
freedom that it offers I can spin all I
want and oh god and I won't be tangled
up in wires now I have a problem because
it didn't I didn't put in my heads
there's a speaker built into it for
convenience which is very nice but for
the sake of my recording and my lavalier
microphone I'm gonna put on headphones
good to know that I can destroy the
elegance that is the wireless system to
put on these big bulky headphones but
hey that's better so this is pistol-whip
this is one of my favorite games in VR
right now it is Bar None amazing I love
it it is so fun if you love beat saber
if you love rhythm games you will love
pistol-whip I've done a video on
pistol-whip I have not done a video on
pistol whip with the freedom of the
oculus quest and having no wife also
I've gotten really really good at pistol
whip don't believe me I'll show you
[Music]
Oh
Wow
[Music]
okay maybe I know exactly where people
are gonna be because I played it a bunch
[Music]
about that swing boy so the reason this
game is awesome
you know another games like beat Sabre
you're just hitting on the beat but here
trying to shoot on the beat and it's
kind of hard but also fun I'm ready oh
wow yeah all right
okay so maybe I didn't do as good in
that one as I wanted to do also it's
good workout so this is the oculus quest
this is the best thing to happen to VR
since VR started I am not exaggerating
in any way shape or form the convenience
of just being able to put on a headset
strap on the controllers and go it's
it's really incredible I can't overstate
it and also the fact that it's 399 which
brings it way down from what other VR
headsets cost it's it's incredible if
you want to find out more about this
there's a link in the description below
even if you don't want to get it but you
just want to find out more about it
click the link down there and check it
out it is awesome in every way shape or
form if you've never tried VR and you
want to give it a try I guarantee you
this is the best starting point because
it not only will give you the best
experience it also won't be a hassle to
set up I have lighthouses from another
VR system I've tried every VR system
this is my favorite and it's got
built-in recording I didn't know that
before today that's really cool it's fun
I love it I love it so much
I think VR is such a good tool for
future entertainment I honestly really
love VR I love the potential of it I
love what it can do and I love seeing it
finally get to the point technology wise
where you can have a great virtual
reality experience anytime you want it
it's right there all in one package done
I love that so if you want to know more
about it click on the link in the
description below right down there and
thank you to oculus for sponsoring this
video and thank you to pistol-whip for
making such an amazing game make more
songs I am itching for more songs so
please more songs thank you and thank
you for watching and as always I will
see you
bye-bye
[Music]